معنا الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد
الجيش السوداني ورئيس مجلس السياده في
السودان سيد البرهان بعد سته ايام من
المعارك والمواجهات الدائره كيف تقيمون
الوضع على الارض
مرحبا ونحن
نتاسف ونتاثر على ما صارت اليه بلادنا
نترحم على كل عزيز بهذه الاحداث
الشعب السوداني لا يستحق ان يستقبل العيد
ويعيش هذه المعاناه الاوضاع طبعا كما
معلوم للجميع سببت فيها 12 شخصيه لقياده
الدعم السريع في الاستيلاء على السلطه
بالقوه
نتحدث على اننا لم نبدا الهجوم وقواتنا
وما زالت تدافع ولم نتحرك حتى الان خارج
مواقعنا فقط يريد ان يعيد الشعب السوداني
نعيد نعيد لهم امل الحياه نريد ان نعيد له
في بناء السويان سودان المستقبل الذي
يرجونه يتمنونه المعارك صحيح
نحن في الخرطوم في كارفور في بعض المواقع
خلال المطار وحول القياده لكن في الولايات
الامور كلها استقرت الان لا يوجد ولا مقر
واحد للدعم السريع في اي من ولايات
السودان كلها اما استسلمت للجيش او تراجعت
بقتال وما حدث اليوم من نهر السوق وحرقه
للمتاجر وقتل المواطنين
هذه المجموعه لا تسعى الى الاستقرار وانما
تزرع الى خرابه دوله وقراب الدوله
السودانيه طيب سيدنا البرهان ماذا عن
الخرطوم والمراكز الاستراتيجيه هناك لماذا
لم يتم الحسم الى حد الان اتحدث عن
القياده العامه والقصر الجمهوري
نحن لا نريد ان ندخل الدوامه صراع تؤثر به
المدنيين قوات الدعم السريع انتشرتات
سكنيه وتقيمها مع المواطنين غير موجوده في
اقسام الشرطه موجوده في اقسام الكهرباء في
كل مكان خذ وهو موجودين وسط الاحياء
السكنيه لا نريد ان يكون قتالهم او محاوله
طردهم سبب لمزيد من المعاناه المواطنين
السودانيه طيب السيد احمد تحدث عن تحييت
90% من سلاح الجو للجيشه السوداني ما دقت
هذه المعلومات
الان لا توجد ولا قاعده عسكريه واحده
طيران تحرك بمسؤوليه ويتحرك بحريه وهو
يتعامل مع الاهداف المنتقى والمحدده ولا
يتعامل عشوائيا نحن قواعد من العسكريه
كلها في قبضه القوات المسلحه
المطارات في الولايات كلها القوات المسلحه
لا يوجد سوى هنا في الخرطوم وجود صحيح في
بعض المواقع
التي لا نزعه
من خلال القتال نحن لا نريد القتال ولا
نريد الحرب نريد ان تنتهي هذه العمليه
باسرع
سوداني يعود مجددا حتى نستقبل ما بداناه
وبداه الثوار الذين دفعوا غاليه لينعموا
بالحريه وليس يحصلوا على دكتاتوريه جديده
تسعى شخصيات محدده لان تحكم سوداء من خلال
البندقيه سيد البرهان تقولون بانكم لا
تريدون الحرب اذا هل يمكن او هل من الواقع
الحديث عن حسم يلغي طرف من الاطراف
الموجوده في السودان او يلغي الجانب الاخر
لو سعينا الى ذلك تمكنا منه نحن لا نريد
ان نزيد من دوامه العنف لا نريد ان نقاتل
وسط الاحياء السكنيه لا نريد ان نقسم
هجماتنا وسط الاحيان سكنيه نريد ان يرعوا
قاده الدعم السريع
لا غير ان يتركز في مواقعهم ويكون القتال
خارجا السكنيه وخارج المدن التي يتضرر بسب
ب اذا ما كيف يمكن ان يكون سيناريو الحل
بتقديرك
انا اتحدث بصوت
نعلمهم جيدا ليست لديهم
12 الاستيلاء على السودان لكن كانت
تطمع في حكم السودان
لا نرى ان هنالك جانب نستطيع ان نجلس معه
الان الجاني هو توعد بانه سيقضي على الجيش
السوداني وتوعد بانه سيحكم السودان وتوعد
السودانيين وما يمارسه افرادهم الان في
الشارع من نهض المواطنين وقتلهم وانتهاك
الحرمات
والسرقه وهذه الامور التي
يراها الجميع هذه امور لا تبشر بان من
يقود هذه القوات يريد ان يحكموا السودان
او يعيد الى بيموت الديمقراطيه هل يعني
ذلك بان المواجهات مستمره ماذا عن الوضع
الانساني هل يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
بالتاكيد نحن
اريد ان يكون القتال في مناطق السكنيه لا
نريد
العملياتنا
وجميع يعلم ذلك حتى الان حتى لا لم نخرج
الى المواجهات في خارج مناطق التواجد
العسكريه لكن امكانيه موجوده لدينا
المقتولات موجوده لدينا ما زال معركه
بداياتها لا نريدها ان تنتهي بصوره عنيفه
يخسر من خلال هذا الوطن كل الان
خساره للسودان خساره للسودانيين فقدناه
ارواح فقدنا ممتلكات الخدمات تدنت البيئه
الصحيه تلاشت الامل الامل في الحياه اصبح
مفقود كثير من السودانيين السودانيين لا
يستحق ان يستقبلوا العيد بهذه الصوره نحن
اذا كانت هنالك اي هدنه نريد ان نضع
القوات كلها خارج المدن
الحكوميه خاليه نريد ان نرى مرافق الدوله
التي تقدم الخدمات تعمل بصوره طبيعيه ليست
لديها سيطره من اي جهه من الجهات قلتم في
حال استمرت المعارك لوحتم باستخدام دعم من
تلجاون الى جلب قوات اضافيه من خارج
الخرطوم هل انتم بحاجه الان للقيام بذلك
هل ستلجاون الى هذه الخطوه
الاخر وتوسع في احتلال المقر الحكوميه
الان هم كلهم قال الشرطه الان دخلوا فيها
مقارن حق خدمات دخلوا فيها كل شيء يقدم
خدمه مسيطرين عليه وكانما يريدون ان
يحرموا السوداني من هذه الخدمات هذه مقاصد
واضحه تريد ان تشير الراي العام السوداني
ضد الدوله معناه ذلك ان هذه الحركه كلها
قامت ضد الدوله ولكن فيما يتعلق
بالتعزيزات هل لجاتم الى استخدام تعزيزات
من خارج الخرطوم ولا يمكن ان يؤدي ذلك الى
تعقيد المشهد وسقوط المزيد من المدنيين
هذا من حقنا ان نحافظ على امن وسياده
الدوله ايضا من واجبنا ان نحافظ على
الدستوريه نظام الحكم ومن اجلنا ان نقدم
الحمايه للمواطنين الذين جارون الشكوى
يوميا يمكنك ان تذهب الى اي من الاحياء
الخرطوم وترى ماذا يفعل جنود الدعم السريع
وخلق السكان وتري بعينه وتسال
الاعمال التي يقومون بها الان التفتيش في
كل مكان تبتز المواطنين تمنع وتفتش
الهويات
الافراد على على خلفيات اسميه وعلى خلفيات
جهويه طيب الجيش تحدث سابقا عن احتمال
وجود تدخل اقليمي دون ان توضحون ماهيه هذا
التدخل هل لك ان توضح لنا عن اي اطراف
اقليميه تتحدثون
التحدث عنها بصوره الرسميه لكن هنالك
معلومات تبعت من من دول
اخرى ولا نتمنى ولا نريد ان يتم ذلك لان
الساحه السودانيه لا تستحمل ان تصبح
تجاذبا اقليميا او دوليا نحن نستطيع ان
ندير معرفتنا لوحدنا نستطيع ان نصل في
نهايه السودانيين لما يرضينا ولما يريدنا
الى بر الامان
هنالك اكثر من جهه دوليه تحاول التدخل من
اجل وقف اطلاق النار
والقيام بهدنه برايك ما هو المطلوب لتحقيق
هدنه حقيقيه الى حد الان تم الاعلان عن
هدنتين دون ان تصمد وحتى دون ان يعني تبقى
لاربعه وعشرين ساعه كل منهما
لا يمكننا ان نتحدث عن
الانتشار للقوات العسكريه
فلنفتح
المقيمين حريه التنقل تتحدث عن هدنه وانت
تقيم الحواجز وتفتش المواطنين تحتل
الخدمات انت تحتل المرافق الرصيف الدوله
يمكن التحدث
هذا استعمار وليس هدنه
طيب من هي الاطراف التي تواصلتم معها على
المستوى
الدوليه والاقليميه الى حد الان فيما
يتعلق من اتصل بكم فيما يتعلق بالوضع
معظم قاده العالم
ومنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه كلها اتصلت
الوان المتحده
الرباعيه ثلاثيه الاتحاد الافريقي
تقريبا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مصر تركيا جنوب السودان
اثيوبيا جيبوتي كثير من الدول حوالينا في
العالم اتصلوا
ليتفاتر ويتراح في كيفيه اعاده الامور
في حال
قبولون بها هي الاكثر ترجيحا لكم
نحن لا نفضل جهه اخرى نحن الاعلى هذا
يعتمد على المطروح
يعيد الى السود
ان واستقراره يعيد الى السودان امنه حتى
سننظر فيه
تحدث عن الجانب الاسرائيلي عن اتصالات
يقوم بها الجانب الاسرائيلي للتوسط في حال
هذه المواجهات هذا ما قاله موقع اكسس وذلك
بطلب امريكي ما دقت هذه المعلومات سيد
البرهان
بهذا الامر لم يتم الاتصال بكم من الجانب
الاسرائيلي
حتى الان
طيب الى حد الان ما زال مجلس السياده
قائما وما زال محمد حمدان حماتي نائبا لكم
هل يعني هذا الحفاظ على الاطار المؤسسي
فقط ام انه هناك امكانيه للعوده الى الوضع
السابق بالحد الادنى
نحن نحافظ على الاطار المؤسسين ونسعى في
تخرج بلدنا باي صيغه من السياق الى بر
الامان ليست لدينا قيود ليس لدينا حدود
لكن لدينا ثوابت وطنيه لدينا امور لا يمكن
ان نتراجع عنها يجب ان يكون هنالك جيش
وطني واحد وهو رب الموضوع سبب قيام الدعم
السريع بمهاجمه القوات المسلحه امامنا
نتحدث عن ضروره توحيد هذا العسكريه ويمكن
ان تكون قوتان عسكريه
السياسي الذي يؤكد المرحله الانتقاليه
وقاموا بهذا الهجوم القادر الذي يعتبره
غدرا وخيار وتمرد على الدوله لاننا كنا
نثق في وجودهم كانوا يتواجدون معنا في كل
مكان في مرافق الخدمه العسكريه
اعود معك الى مجلس السياده يعني لم يتل لم
يتم عزل لحمتي الى حد الان لم يتم اتخاذ
اي قرار بحق احمدتي لماذا على الرغم من
هذه المواجهات
لكل لكل زمان
سياتي في
حينه وما الذي يؤخر ذلك ان سمحت لي
نحن نعلم لدينا استراتيجينا نعمل بموجبها
تتخذ في توقيتها المناسب هناك سؤال يعود
الى الواجهه هل المعارك الدائره اليوم هي
فقط بسبب رفض اندماج الدعم السريع في
الجيش ام ان المساله تكشف عن خلافات اعمق
كانت تحت
هذا هو هذا هو احد اسباب الخلاف الاخر
يعلمه قاده الدعم جيدا لانه حاول الله
يستولوا على الدوله السودانيه بكل مؤسفات
نحن دوما نرفض ذلك انا لا اريد ان اخوتي
التفاصيل لكن واحد الخلاف انهم يريدون ان
يغيروا ما حدث
مصالحهم الشخصيه ايضا يريدون ان يجدوا
الاتفاق
الذي كان يفترضا يوقع في ايضا لصالحي هذا
الاتفاق فيه نص واضح على دمج الدعم السريع
اذا كلها مرتبط بها 12 شخصيه تخش تخص
اشخاص نحن في العسكريه هذه القوات التي
تقاتل الان لا تقاتل نيابه عن البرهان لان
القتال في كل مكان الى السودان 18 فيها
قتال لم يتحدث احد عن البرهان وانما يتحدث
الجميع عن وحده السودان يتحدث الجميع عن
وحده العسكريه يتحدث جميع عن ام الموا
وسلامتهم لكن هنالك جهاز تحدث عن وجود
حسنيه وجود في السلطه
محمد حمدان تحدثت معه اكثر من مره اننا
اذا كنا السبب في مشاكل السودانيه يجب ان
نتنحى يجب ان نذهب سويا هو يقول لي
ويريد ان يبقى يريد ان يحكم يريد ان يسيطر
على السودان طيب سيد البرهان على الرغم من
ان في المقابله التي اجراها مع الجزيره
قال بانه يعني يحافظ على الديمقراطيه
ويتمسك بها
تاتي عن طريق البندقيه
الديمقراطيه اولى طرقها التحصل عليها هي
عمل جماهيري العمل الشعبي العمل التنظيمي
العمل الذي لا لا لا لا ابدا السلاح كل ما
استخدم السلاح
الديمقراطيه
لكن الجيش اليوم ايضا يستخدم السلاح
الجيش دافع عن البلد ويدافع عن حقه
الدستوري في منع فئه معينه تريد ان تستخدم
السلاح لتحتل هذه الدوله
اعود معك الى الوضع الانساني سيد البرهان
هل يمكن ان يكون ذلك مدخلا لهدنا تتحول
الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
كما ذكرت سابقا هذا يرتبط بنوعيه هذه
الهدنه وكيف يمكن ان تنزل على الارض بدون
ان تؤثر على اعمال المواطنين العاديه ما
نوعيه الهدنه المقبوله لديكم
كنا لا توفر اي فرصه للاشباك مد ما تعطي
المواطنين حقهم في التنقل بحريه هدنه تقفل
المواطنين الحصول على الخدمات الضروريه
خذنا تكفي الحريه التنقل بين مدن السودان
مختلفه الان مدن الطرق كلها غير واصف
جامعات من الدعم السريع هي تفتش الافراد
وتبحث سويات
وياخذون الافكار
يعني الان الدعم السريع الامن
يمكن ان نسمي
سيد البرهان السودانيون وحتى الاطراف
الدوليه عبروا عن مخاوف من ان الانقسام قد
يصل الى حد المساس ببنيه الدوله خاصه
بالنظر لمناطق انتشار الجيش والدعم السريع
جغرافيا ما العمل لتفادي ذلك في ظل الظروف
الراهنه
الان الان كل الفرق العسكريه في فاشل ما
فيش
المسلحه في
دمازين فيك 18 ولايه الان لا توجد مشكله
بين المواطنين والقوات المسلحه هذه
المشكله مشتعله فقط هنا في الخرطومين الان
في كل مكان في السودان الجميع يعيش في امن
واستغرام كل ما نتحدث عن هذه المشكله تقسم
السوداني
يتعدد حديثا غير صحيحا كان سوداني موحدين
في كل السودان خلف القوات المسلحه هنالك
حديث عن انه الدعم يقاتل الاسلاميين
ها في دعم بعض الجهات التي تعادي
السودانيات لاي نظام اسلامي
الاسلاميين المتطرفين نظراء مع الدعم
السريع الطرفين يريدون نستولوا على
الحكم الاسلاميين لهم بما يستولى على
الحكم ولا الدعم السريع له بان يحتوي على
الحكم طيب اذا مشاكل الحسم ما امكانيه
الحل في هذه الحاله سيد البرهان
الدعم السرير وعادت الى مواقعها واخلص
العاصمه نستطيع ان نجلس معها من تبقى منهم
لكي نتفاوض لكن في هذه الظروف الحسم الا
اظن ان هنالك خيار اخر غير الحكم العسكري
هناك مخاوف من تزايد الغذائيه وانقطاع
المياه والكهرباء وخروج مستشفيات عن
الخدمه الى اي حد يمكن ان يتحمل
السودانيون بتقديرك سيد البرهان
ودعم اكثر من اربعه خمسه مستشفيات وحولتها
لمراكز علاجيه لافرادهم الان معظم الخدمات
الدعم في تعصيلا نحن لا نريد ان نرى
سودانيين بهذه المعاناه اذا ما عزلنا ان
نستسلم
الدوله
دفعنا هذا الامر معنى ذلك اننا سنسلم
جهه عمل لمصالحها الشخص
لا لخدمه
السودانيين جميعا
هل خروج قوات الدعم السريع من الخرطوم
ممكن ان يشكل حافزا للعوده للجلوس معهم
هل هذا هو الشرط
اكيد
عدد كما كانت في ابريل او في ديسمبر عند
توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي العام الماضي حتما
سيكون هنالك وضع مختلف طيب بهذه الحاله مع
من تقبلون التفاوض في حال تم لكم ذلك
اي وساطه نقبلا سنتحدث معه لن نتحدث
مباشره مع قاده الدعم السريع مره اخرى
وهذه القوات من يتولى امرها اصبح خارج عن
القانون او متمرد نحن افراد الدعم السريع
وضباط جزء كبير منهم للقوات المسلحه ليست
لدينا معه مشكله الاشكال شيء من يقف على
راس هذه
طيب تتحدثون عن قوات الدعم السريع وتقولون
ان خروجها من الخرطوم قد يشكل منطلقا
للجلوس معها ولكن مع من تقبلون من قوات
الدعم السريع الجلوس
والتحاول نحن نقبل على الاطراف التي تريد
الكلام على الطرف التي تريد الحوار لا
يمكن المجلس تريد الحرب وتريد ذلك سيد
القران
الكريم مؤسسه لديها مستشارين سياسيين
لديها حلفاء سياسيين لديها اشخاص يمكن
يتحدثون عنها هذه المؤسسه العسكريه لمن
صنع افرادها للتعليمات العسكريه انا لا
اظن ان هنالك مجال للحديث عن السياسه مره
اخرى مع الدعم السريع هنالك من يتخوف سيد
البرهان ان طالت هذه المواجهات ان تؤدي
الى حرب اهليه في السودان ما تعليقكم
لا اظن ان الحرب الاهليه تقع بسبب هذه
الاطماع الشخصيه من افراد السودانيين
جميعا يعرفون ان هذه الحرب وراها 12
لاشخاص محدودين يريدون ان يحكموا هذه
الدوله السودانيه ويستولوا على مقدراته
وعلى امكانياته هنالك من يخشى من استخدام
ورقه القبائل
الان القبائل قالت كلمتها
قالت انها ليست مع الحرب قال بانها مع
السلام قالت
القوات المسلحه مؤسسه الوطنيه لا تنتمي
اليها
عقيده عسكريه معروفه لديها واجبات دستوريه
منصوبه عليها هي تقوم بواجبها من خلال ذلك
القران يسر ومن بعد سوداني
سيد البرهان هل رسبتم اي دعم خارجي لطرف
الاخر
لم تقدم لنا اي جهاز دعمي حتى نستطيع
نحن نعمل بامكانياتنا ماذا عن الطرف الاخر
هذا سطم اي دعم يصل اليه
ايضا
رفضنا اي دعومات لن نسمح لها بان تصل الى
الطرف الاخر
للتعقيدات الكبيره في المشهد واتساع
المعارك بين الجيش والدعم هل يمكن ان يكون
الدعم السريع هل يمكن ان يكون احتمالات
الحل ونهايه الازمه هو تسليم الطرفين
لمؤسسات الحكم الى جهه مدنيه
الدائره المواجهات فقط في هذه المدينه في
الخرطوم فقط في العصر
في محاوله نهب السوء حول اغراض من الدعم
السريع وليس كلهم محاوله نهض السوق
النظاميه سيد البرهان
هل يمكن ان يعجل من تسليم السلطه الى جهه
مدنيه هنا السؤال
نحن مبكرا تحدثنا عن تسليم السلطه لجهه
مدنيه تحدثنا عن هذا المبكر متى كان هنالك
شكرا لك الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
قائد الجيش السوداني ورئيس مجلس السياده
في السودان